today on the free pilot training channel
we're going to be diving into the
details on vfr sectionals
specifically today we're going to be
talking all about airports
first let's take a look at the basic
airport symbol which is a magenta circle
these symbols let us know that in these
locations we have other than hard
surface runways in other words grass or
dirt
these could also mean that there is a
hard surface runway here but it's less
than one thousand five hundred feet long
now as you can see here a lot of these
magenta circles have letters or symbols
inside of them
here are a few examples of what you
might find inside of these circles
now while an empty circle indicates that
this airfield is for public use
this h here lets us know that this
airfield is specifically for helicopters
circles with an f inside like this one
tell us that this airfield is
specifically for an ultralight flight
park
now when you see this magenta circle
with a u inside this means that the
airfield is unverified
this might mean that there's a lack of
information on that runway
or there might be some weird operating
limitations that apply here
circles with an r inside are probably
the most common symbols
these indicate restricted airports
usually
these are private airfields and you need
permission prior to using these
unless of course you're an emergency
aircraft speaking of emergencies if you
ever see this magenta circle with an x
inside
this indicates an abandoned airport
typically these are only charted if
they're at least 3000 feet long and that
makes these great places to make an
emergency landing
now on rare occasion you might see the
symbol with the word objectionable
beside it
the faa believes that there's something
unsafe or hazardous about this airfield
a lot of times it's some kind of
obstacle that makes this airfield
hazardous
but you never know what's lurking at the
end of the runway the next type of
airport symbol you might run across is
one like this
if you look closely you'll see a small
depiction of the runway surrounded by a
solid magenta circle
when we see this symbol we know that
this airfield has a hard surface runway
from 1 500 feet to 8 069 foot long
i'm sorry that they chose such a random
number for the upper limit of these
runways
comment below if you know the reason why
they did this
now notice some of these airports have
little tick marks surrounding the
airport symbol
these mean that the airport is supposed
to have fuel services
but if you're going on a long trip i
recommend calling first because
sometimes these smaller airfields can
run out of fuel
now if you look closer you'll notice
that this airport has a star on top of
it
this indicates that this airport has a
rotating beacon and rotating beacons are
important for a couple reasons
first they make it easier to find the
airport at night they also help you
identify that you're at the correct type
of airport
for example take a look at this beacon
on the top of this control tower
at normal civilian airfields these
beacons alternate between green
and white similar to the way this beacon
is flashing now
military airfields on the other hand
flash with one green and two quick white
flashes
green white white green
white white
now if you ever see a beacon flashing
white yellow green that would indicate a
heliport
and obviously that's for helicopters so
you wouldn't want to try to land there
and last but not least alternating white
and yellow lights indicate a water
airport for seaplanes
now while there's no requirement for
them to do it some airports operate
their beacon
when the weather is below vfr minimums
and when they do this they typically use
the general vfr weather minimums of a
thousand foot ceilings and three statute
miles visibility
before we continue with the lesson did
you know that the free pilot training
channel has its own merchandise store
you can buy hoodies t-shirts and all
kinds of different cool merchandise
to show your friends that you're getting
the best free pilot training available
if you don't mind supporting this
channel and looking cool at the same
time be sure to check out that link in
the description below
now if you look back at our vfr
sectional you'll notice that some of
these airports are blue
this lets us know that this airfield has
a control tower
that means anytime you see a magenta
airfield these are untowered
now take a look at this bigger airport
in this class c air space
just like the smaller airport we just
mentioned this one's blue so we know it
has a control tower
if you'll notice this airport is no
longer surrounded by a circle
but now the runways are outlined with
dark markings when we see this we know
that this airport has at least one hard
surface runway
greater than 8069 feet long now take
this with a grain of salt because if
there are multiple runways
they can be less than 8069 feet
now check this out this airport also has
a beacon
but on these larger airfields they try
to match it to the location on the
airfield
speaking of that take a look at this
little dot on this airfield
when you see these these depict a vor a
vor dme
or vortac in its approximate location on
the field
we'll talk more about those in a future
lesson now i want to draw your attention
to this little anchor
this tells us that there's a c-plane
base here this particular example is an
untowered seaplane base but check out
this one
not only does it have a control tower
but it also has fuel services
now let's break down the airport
information label
on the first line we see the airport's
name along with its location identifier
on the second line notice the letter c t
here followed by a frequency
this lets us know that this airfield has
a control tower which we already knew
because the runways are blue
and this is the frequency that it uses
now check out this little star
this means that the tower only operates
part time if you wanted to see the hours
that it operated you would have to look
in the chart supplement
this c stands for ctaf when the tower is
not operational
this frequency reverts to the common
traffic advisory frequency
now notice the frequency where we can
get our weather in this case
we have adis but different airfields
have different weather reporting
services
that's a lesson for another day next we
have our field elevation
in feet above mean sea level and here at
this airport the elevation
is 55 msl now this l next to it
lets us know that we have lighting in
operation from sunset to sunrise
and that little asterisk next to it
indicates that some lighting limitations
exist we'd have to look in the chart
supplement to see exactly what those
were further to the right this number
tells us the length of our longest
runway and hundreds of feet
in other words the longest runway on
this airfield is eleven thousand feet
long
now as i'm sure you're already aware in
the standard traffic pattern you make
left hand turns
but some airports want you to make right
patterns on some of the runways for one
reason or another
these are indicated right here by an rp
followed by which runways are right
patterns
now this aoe you see here is not a
normal
informational note but it stands for
airport of entry and this is a place
where you can get customs and border
services
anytime you run across weird information
like this on your vfr sectional
be sure you pull out your aeronautical
chart user's guide you can download this
document for free from the faa's website
and this is the best tool available for
deciphering vfr sectionals
i hope you enjoyed today's video on vfr
sectionals
if you did would you consider
subscribing and be sure to check out
these videos if you want to get yourself
one step closer to that private pilot
certificate